[Musique]
deux gars là j'aurais vous en 2030
l'espérance de vie augmente ainsi
mécaniquement la population vieillit
aujourd'hui dans le haut rhin 65 mille
personnes sont âgées de plus de 75 ans
d'ici dix ans elles seront 90 milles
derrière les chiffres
une réalité celle de la perte
d'autonomie la proportion de personnes
dépendantes devant doubler d'ici 2050
comment assurer au mieux leur prise en
charge quels outils pour permettre à
tous de bien vieillir
autant de questions auxquelles le
conseil départemental du haut-rhin
souhaite dès à présent trouver des
réponses
jeudi dernier l'institution présenter
son plan senior clairement la priorité
pour le département du haut rhin
ce sont les seniors vous savez que notre
mission principale dans les départements
c'est la solidarité
c'est notre coeur de mission mais c'est
également notre mission de coeur l'an
dernier notre priorité dans le domaine
de la solidarité était lié à la
protection de l'enfance
nous avons l'an dernier recruté 15
personnes supplémentaires dans le
domaine de la protection de l'enfance
cette année et les années à venir
la priorité sera les seniors pour le
lancement des plans seniors c les pattes
de soultzmatt qui a été choisi il faut
dire que la structure a reçu un
financement du département pour réaliser
d'importants travaux les cette année et
pour les neuf années à venir ce sont 8
millions d'euros qui vont être investis
dans la rénovation de neuf ehpad haut
rhinois travailler sur le bâti c'est
aussi améliorer la qualité de vie des
résidents aujourd'hui à des besoins
d'aménagement les standards de vie ne
sont plus les mêmes que ceux d'il ya 10
ou 15 ans on ne vend ne vit plus
aujourd'hui dans une chambre à 2 dans un
ehpad
on a besoin d'aménager les douches
d'élargir les portes pour les accès aux
personnes à mobilité réduite
tous ces aménagements pourront être
faits et les communes les attendaient
depuis déjà un certain
vous voir rester chez soi le plus
longtemps possible c'est le désir de
l'immense majorité des personnes âgées
adapter son logement à une perte
d'autonomie progressive c'est possible
de nombreuses solutions existent sur le
marché des financements peuvent même
être débloqués pour soutenir les plus
modestes ainsi sur les trois prochaines
années le conseil départemental prévoit
une enveloppe de 2 millions d'euros pour
soutenir l'adaptation des logements le
maintien à domicile c'est chose très
simple c'est une barre de douche
c'est une adaptation du c'est une
transformation de baignoires en douche
c'est une c'est une rampe ou pour monter
les escaliers qui permettent de garder
la personne à domicile en facilitant son
sa vie tous les jours ces soldes
investissements qui sont compatibles
avec le budget d'une famille jusqu'à
présent il fallait trois dossiers il
fallait des mois il fallait plusieurs
guichet notre objectif c'est de
raccourcir la procédure c'est de la
simplifier et d'accélérer de manière à
pouvoir en faire bénéficier un plus
grand nombre de personnes dans le
département
diddy maintien à domicile des personnes
aidantes mais venir en aide à un proche
en perte d'autonomie peut s'avérer
difficile pour les aidants familiaux
gérés vie professionnelle familiale et
soit auprès d'un parent peut mener à des
situations d'épuisement objectifs du
plan senior aider les aidants on a
plusieurs manière d'accompagner les
aidants mais une manière qui nous paraît
important c'est de pouvoir à ce qu'on va
voir ce qu'on appelle le droit au répit
c'est à dire que à un moment donné il
faut que la personne aidante puisse
souffler un peu puisse puisse poser ses
valises et quel don qu'elle puisse à
moment donné on comprit serment et
prendre en charge la personne
accompagnée dans des sites soit dans des
situations d'urgence soit parce qu'un
moment pour pouvoir souffler dans un
moment donc d'avoir déposé des places
d'accueil de jour qui permettent aux
aidants
de facile de leur faut leur faciliter la
vie si en france nous avons la chance de
disposer d'un très haut niveau de
qualité des soins
on se rend compte qu'il vaut mieux
prévenir que guérir objectif du conseil
départemental et de l' agence régionale
de santé
rééquilibrer la balance entre curatif
prévenu en fait c'est la prévention de
la perte d'autonomie
la caisse nationale qui alimentait par
le jour férié supplémentaire le lundi de
pentecôte à louer des budgets pour
prévenir la perte d'autonomie que ce
soit aux personnes à domicile ou aux
personnes n'est pas par exemple en
faisant faire de la marche en leur
faisant travailler la mémoire en les
accompagnant sur des sorties et c'est
plus de 200 actions que nous paraît que
nous finançons avec la la censad de
manière à pouvoir retarder les effets du
vieillissement
parce que pour nous ce qui est important
c'est qu'effectivement la personne soit
l'acteur de son projet de vie c'est le
sens du schéma départemental d'autonomie
qui nous ont proposé ces derniers mois
les ehpad ont été la cible de nombreuses
critiques certains professionnels du
secteur pointant des cas de maltraitance
bien qu'aucun établissement haut rhinois
et été spécifiquement ciblé le conseil
départemental a tout de même souhaité
mener l enquête
pour l'heure l'institution n'a pas
détecté de dysfonctionnements alors nous
avons fait un sondage dans le haut-rhin
auprès des personnes âgées qui sont en
ehpad et auprès de 300 personnes à
travers tout le territoire et il en est
ressorti que plus de 70% des personnes
âgées qui sont en ehpad dans le haut
rhin sont satisfaites
les motifs le cas échéant
d'insatisfaction sont notamment liés
à l'alimentation qui est importante et
ça veut dire qu'il ya des progrès à
faire dans ce domaine
mais on peut dire aujourd'hui que dans
le rhin on vit plutôt bien dans nos
ehpad ya encore des progrès à faire et
c'est justement pour ces progrès la
cette marge de progrès qui infère que le
conseil départemental des blocs des
crédits et c'est pour cela que notre
priorité cette année les années à venir
ce sont les seniors faire face au
vieillissement un enjeu de société
majeur au delà de son soutien financier
c'est l'ensemble des citoyens que le
conseil départemental souhaite mobiliser